hello good morning we'll take a quick
shot while you guys settle down so so
one thing I want to before I introduce
my boss which is always my favorite part
of the conference I want to emphasize
the the community aspect of of the news
challenge we run the news challenge it's
gonna be twice this year and we would
not be able to pull it off were it not
for the people who raised their hands
and come help us read review ask
questions of the in this instance the
700 entries this year we had over 30
people either come meet with us in Miami
gather at Mozilla's office in San
Francisco do bi-weekly video chats where
we went through entries and so some of
you are in the room who did that I just
wanted if you guys could raise your
hands or even stand up for a second
stand up you guys you guys would did
such a lot of work so it's just a matter
v of the of the community that took part
in that for us so so thank you so in
introducing Alberto I wanted I thought
about the fact that this news challenge
question ended up being very broad right
it was a notion of how might we
strengthen the internet for free
expression and innovation and as we
wrestled with that question and I said
oh there this feels really open and
broad I'm a little nervous and I won't
say I won't quote them word for word but
I will say it's really nice to have a
boss who doesn't just who's not just
comfortable with ambiguity but embraces
it and really does embrace openness and
and jumping into a project in a news
challenge when we weren't really sure
what we were going to get so he'll tell
you what what we're gonna get Alberto
fact is we don't really know what we're
going to get we know what we're going to
fund and then we'll see what we're going
to get thanks John and and I what I want
to do is I want to I want to announce
the winners of this round of the news
challenge and then I want to talk a
little bit about about open Internet and
about what's going on at the FCC and try
to enlist some of your good minds in in
an effort to ensure that the internet
the internet stays free and accessible
I'll thank again our our colleagues at
the Media Lab and and Ethan as John
indicated when the when the content when
the night news challenge contest started
when we began to think about it nine
years ago with Eric Newton and Gary
Kebbell it was a contest to find and
support ideas to use digital platforms
to deliver news and information to
communities and I remember one of our
trustees and well can you give us a
notion about what you might fund and I
said no because if I did then I'd be
cheating the fact of the matter is this
has to be like a you know like a 12-step
program the first thing you do is you
say my name is Alberto and I'm an
alcoholic and you say no my name is
Knight Foundation and I don't know what
we're doing and you have to say now we
happen though to have some money do you
happen to have some ideas and happily a
lot of people in this room did I'm
making light of it but but but it really
is serious business it is serious
business about not prescribing and about
not saying these are the things that we
have we had an idea when we were talking
in the office the other day we have some
money would you do it the answer is
almost always yes and that's almost
always a bad grant you need to be able
to let you need to be able to let go and
I think that's probably the hardest
thing in philanthropy in the last couple
of years we've moved the focus of the
contest from a completely open in
general
to somewhat more focus to networks to
mobile to open government data to health
data and of course this one is on how to
strengthen internet for free expression
and as in the past we welcome the
participation of readers and thank I'm
joined John in thanking them and I
especially want to thank this year Ford
Foundation and Mozilla Foundation for
their participation and thank them for
their insightful advice their hard work
and their resources that they applied to
to the contest it's always better with
partners I think you'll find that the
winners each in their diverse areas work
under the still broad umbrella concept
at the end of the day I suspect that is
in the past the most successful winners
are going to be the ones that have found
solutions to practical challenges so
I'll announce the winners now and then I
want to come back and I want to and I
want to talk a little bit more about
what's happening at the FCC with with
open Internet and then Michael Maness my
colleague will lead a discussion with
with the winners about their projects so
here are the winners the first one is
check out the internet from the New York
Public Library bridging the digital
divide by allowing New York residents
with limited broadband access to borrow
portable Wi-Fi hotspots devices for up
to a year it's half a million dollars
and the project leads our Tony Marx and
Jim English I don't know they're here
Tony I know is here congratulations to
them
code 240 ensuring the future of the
Internet as a diverse inclusive public
resource by opening more pathways for
underrepresented even on
underrepresented minorities to top jobs
in technology and bolstering
professional support networks to sustain
their success $400,000 Laura Weidman
powers as the project lead Laura getting
it right on rights from the digital
Public Library of America creating a
simplified and MoU coherent rights
structure for content collections from
libraries museums archives and other
sources along with best practices that
institutions can use safely to make more
content available to the public
$300,000 the project leads our Dan Cohen
and Emily Gore Globus global censorship
measurement from the open technology
Institute at New America working in
support of measurement labs a
collaboration that hosts a suite of
tools for assessing the openness of the
internet award is $350,000 and the
project leads our Ben Scott Thomas
Gideon and Alan Davidson
[Applause]
Internet to go from the Chicago Public
Library offering Chicago residents Wi-Fi
hotspots for up to three weeks at a time
in addition to one on one digital
literacy and skills coaching and access
to online tutorials the award is
$400,000 and the project leads our brian
Bannon michelle frisk and andrew medlar
I suppose the winners if they're here
they can stand up and wave if not we'll
still send the check thank you go online
censorship dot org from electronic
freedom foundation for an Electronic
Frontier Foundation collecting
information about online censorship
incidents to explore concerns about
censorship and preserve freedom of
expression $250,000 and the Project Lead
is Jillian York ranking digital rights
from New America Foundation developing a
system for benchmarking and ranking the
world's most powerful tech companies on
how well they protect the free
expression and privacy of users $300,000
the Project Lead is Rebecca MacKinnon
texts secure from open whisper systems
safeguarding mobile text communications
through a simple secure messaging
application that requires no special
knowledge from the user I'm not sure
what that exactly means to be honest
with you but John will explain it to you
later on after the program the award is
four hundred sixteen thousand dollars
which is a really strange amount as it's
usually rounded to surprise this wasn't
five hundred but it's four hundred
sixteen thousand and the Project Lead is
Moxie Marlinspike who are the
gatekeepers from journalism development
networks examining the gatekeepers of
Eastern Europe's digital infrastructure
by analyzing the ownership and
connections of Internet service
providers and cable satellite operators
two hundred thousand dollars to Paul
Radu and Manuela Proteus and
congratulations to all of the winners
that's our that's our complete list you
will see them here some of them in in a
few moments so over the years we've
we've moved the the night news challenge
from from topic to topic we haven't yet
decided on the topic for the topic for
the next one but we think that that the
subject of a free and universal web of a
free and accessible Internet is hardly
exhausted with one attempt on on our
part and that perhaps we should have a
repeat and maybe a more somehow more
focused attention and I will acknowledge
to you that we don't have the answer
about even what to call this or how to
focus this and the point of doing this
next part here is asking for your help
your assistance your good thoughts on
what would be effective if you had
this amount of money to invest in
projects to ensure the openness and
accessibility of the Internet how would
you do it right now the FCC is
considering rulemaking that would tear
the could tear the Internet it could
allow certain providers who are able to
pay to have access to higher speed and
quality of Internet than to others who
cannot the debate is on as to whether
this tearing of access to Internet is a
necessary byproduct of our economic
system and will provide even better
services for those who can afford them
or whether this is essentially
anti-democratic since internet is the
public square and there may be no
barriers to citizens to join their
public square if you're rich and
connected you're okay if you work for
MIT if you work for Knight Foundation or
if you work for Exxon you're likely to
have the highest speed that's just the
fact if you're on your own you may not
if you're individuals if you're an
individual developer or the people who
use your programs don't have the money
you may not we started about nine years
ago looking for ways to deliver news on
digital platforms to everyone in our
communities so everyone could be better
informed and determine everyone's own
interest to foster engagement in those
communities and thereby build an even
stronger democracy we wanted to build
networks of emergently emerging leaders
such as yourselves who would champion
those informed communities and frankly
we had a sense of news dissemination
which came from a new from our newspaper
background newspaper and television
where the delivery of news and
information was assumed to be general
assumed to be cheap or assumed to be
free it was not in the in the in the way
of thinking of of cable which is
expensive or of tearing which ups the
ante even more
so in light of the real world the
hardball politics that's going on in DC
I I come to think that we were probably
extremely naive nine years ago to think
that if this thing worked that we could
continue exploring a free and open
Internet with a free and open Internet I
want to read to you a fairly long piece
from from Larry Lessig's wonderful
review in the New Republic some years
ago critiquing the movie social network
when it first came out and I want to
read it to you because I thought it was
first of all I thought it was as good as
any review of a movie review I've ever
read it was as insightful about the
movie as it was entertaining to read but
I want to read it to you because his
comments about the movie then and about
Internet are absolutely relevant to
where we are right now remember this was
written as commentary about a movie
Larry Lessig what is important is suck
in Zuckerberg story is not that he's a
socially clumsy boy genius and it's not
that he invented an amazing product
through hard work and insight that
millions loved the history of American
entrepreneurism is just that history
instead what's important here is that
Zuckerberg genius could be embraced by
half a billion people within six years
of its first being launched without and
here's the critical bed asking
permission of anyone the real story is
not the invention it is the platform
that makes the inventions sing
Zuckerberg didn't invent that platform
he was a hacker a term of praise who
built for it the venn compares Facebook
to Nantucket nectars which is a another
company that that is its students of his
I guess that had had developed and he
says at each step after the first along
the way to giving their customers what
they wanted the founders of Nantucket
nectars had to ask permission from
someone they needed permission from a
manufacturer to get into his plant they
needed permission from
distributor to get into her Network and
permission from stores you got the idea
and he goes on they made this log and
succeeded but many try and that's log
and fail some for good reasons sometimes
not zuckerberg faced no such barrier for
less than $1000 he could get his idea
onto the internet he needed no
permission from the network provider he
needed no clearance from Harvard to
offer it to Harvard students neither
with Yale or Princeton or Stanford nor
with every other community he invited in
because the platform of the Internet is
open and free or in the language of the
day because it is a neutral Network a
billion Mark Zuckerberg have the
opportunity to invent for that flat for
that platform including all of the
people in this room and and though there
are crucial partners who are essential
to bring the product to market the cost
of proving viability on this platform
has dropped dramatically the tragedy of
this film is that practically everyone
watching it will miss the point
practically everyone walking out will
think they understand genius on the
internet but almost none will have seen
the real genius here and that is the
tragedy because just at the moment when
we celebrate the product of these two
wonders Zuckerberg and the internet
working together policymakers are
conspiring for this is Larry Lessig on
dev I am a neutral foundation president
I'm just I'm just saying just as we
celebrate the product of these two
wonders working together policymakers
are conspiring ferociously with old
world powers to remove the conditions
for this success as network neutrality
gets bargained away to add insult to
injury by an administration that was
elected with the promise to defend it
the opportunities for Zuckerberg zuv
tomorrow will shrink and as they do we
will return more to the world where
success depends upon permission and
privilege and insiders and were fewer
turned their souls to inventing
the next great idea that was several
years ago I cannot tell you how much I
believe that is relevant today as a
longtime advocate of First Amendment
freedoms I I have a I've spent a
lifetime believing and working for the
right to speak because we are citizens
not because we are given permission to
speak or because we bought a license to
speak and I believe we should do
everything possible to ensure that the
right to speak the right of expression
on Internet is just that a right not a
license subject to approval so this
night news challenge as John told you
attracted more than 700 innovative ideas
from journalism policy research
education fields and as we go forward
how do we design a challenge a question
perhaps that will help keep the internet
free we really do want your advice how
to strengthen the internet to stay open
to stay authentic how do we do this work
its scale what tools can we build and
teach to enable anyone to use the web
securely and in the coming months we'll
do more work and build a stronger
internet we will probably make an
announcement about what the what the the
contest will be toward the toward the
end of the summer but I really cannot
more strongly encourage you to think
about this this should matter to you
this has to matter to you if you have
ideas about this I want you to send them
to me AI at night foundation org I
promise you we will we may not do it but
I promise you that we will consider your
ideas seriously you might also want to
look at this condensed version of the
FCC notice at at a site you've got the
the
at the Dan Schultz and Matt Carroll
built this this over the weekend in
Mozilla open web hackathon it's a really
nice I just read it this morning it's a
really nice summary of the of the
background the context the issues and
again I encourage you if you do read
that and have an opinion I encourage you
to speak up and give feedback at the I
know this sounds ryu this looks really
inviting doesn't it this is this was
done by somebody who believes in human
centered design Ethan what have you been
doing you should go down to the FCC and
fix this anyhow this is you've got it
this is an opportunity though quite
seriously an opportunity for everybody
in this room to have your voice heard
and again if you have ideas for the
contest I ask you to contact me directly
so that's the end of the pitch now I
want to invite Michael Maness to lead us
through discussion with the winners and
also to talk a little bit about I think
you're going to talk a little bit about
the winners of the prototype fund grants
so Michael Maness thank you thanks
Alberto so we're gonna do I'm Michael
maintenance I'm the VP of journalism and
media innovation at night and ask the
official lumberjack at the knight
foundation so we're gonna do a quick
round of talks where we have each of the
winners come up we're gonna do a short
presentation on it we're not gonna have
questions in this but you'll be able to
find them outside and I hope that you do
especially to engage with a lot of this
great work that they're doing so we're
gonna go one by one they're gonna come
up do a little lightning round and we'll
go through at that pace so first up we
have Tony marks and check out the
Internet Tony
[Music]
hey everybody I'm Tony marks on the
president of the New York Public Library
and you may think I'm in the wrong place
19th century institution par excellence
trying to transform itself for the 21st
century with your help and I want to say
thank you first off to Alberto - John -
Michael - Everett at the knight
Foundation and to all the folks who
contributed to this project that we're
beginning so we are still a physical
library in fact we are the largest
library system in America the public
libraries of New York combined have
about 40 million physical visits a year
that's more than all the cultural
institutions and professional sporting
teams in New York combined and of course
we have to use those facilities as best
we can and people rely on us a third of
New Yorkers rely on us because they
can't afford books a third of New
Yorkers rely on us because they don't
have computers at home
we are massively increasing our
educational programs and that includes
in the arena of computer skills and
access we are on the way to having about
150,000 spots for free basic computer
skills training
we're the largest free provider of that
training in New York we're now offering
coding instruction particularly in the
South Bronx and in Harlem because we are
in the poorest neighborhoods and that's
an industry as you're going to hear from
colleagues that needs much more
diversity and more talent so we hope to
contribute to that we're trying to be
creative where the leading
non-university partner with Coursera now
so that we can do blended learning in
the libraries as well as with Khan
Academy and there's so much more that we
can do when I first got to the library I
was disheartened to learn that most of
the commercial publishers were not
allowing libraries to land electronic
books I envisioned a future in which a
third of New York and people around the
country relying on their public
libraries to be able to read would
simple
not have access to books if they chose
to read them electronically so that
seemed like a nightmare scenario a
technology that wants to increase access
was going to collapse it we happily are
headquartered where the publishing
industry is headquartered we shamed them
no sorry we'd negotiated with them
anyway the and and got the entire
commercial publishing industry to let
libraries lend licensed electronic books
that's now a national opportunity for
all libraries and that's fantastic and
the coding and the computer skills is
fantastic and we said okay now we're
gang gaining more content we're working
together with the digital Public Library
of America as founding partners of their
great work getting more of our amazing
collections available we hope eventually
everything online for free anytime
anywhere that's the holy grail that
we're all all after but as we walk
through towards that Holy Grail we
noticed a more immediate threat right at
home
so let's see if this works whoops nope
wrong way there we go thank you so
immediate threat right at home
something like 46 so close to 50% of New
York City households that have incomes
below 35,000 do not have computer access
at home in the city of New York roughly
a third of all households do not have
computers or broadband at home they're
in the neighborhood I live in near
Columbia it's probably 90 95 percent
saturation in the South Bronx and Harlem
it's probably closer to 90 percent of
non-access people can't afford the razor
blades and so they don't even buy the
razors that means we could have all the
content in the world and pump it out for
free and people can't get it it's why
people are lining up in the libraries to
wait for our computers it's when we
close the libraries during a
in the evening people are sitting on our
stoop to get leaked broadband that's
when a light went off for us we said no
we got to be able to do better than this
libraries are no longer constrained by
walls our provision of access should no
longer be constrained by walls so we
said what can we what can we do well it
helps that we are in every neighborhood
including in every poor neighborhood
we said let's leak purposefully into
those neighborhoods we think we asked
ourselves what's the best technology you
all will know this better than I turns
out we think MiFi cell hotspots is the
way to go
$40 for a little gizmo and I'm sorry
Maya let's use that word in this group
the $40 for a little gizmo and $10 a
month for subscriptions we tried with a
hundred to learn as we went and now
thanks to the knight foundation and we
hope another million and a half dollars
that we're gonna try to find we'll have
ten thousand people or ten thousand
households where we will give you this
device we will pay the subscription we
will give it to you in particular if
you're involved in one of our education
programs and the Newark Public Library
will soon have something like four
hundred thousand people in education
programs that in itself is a means test
because so we decided that works we can
supplement our educational programs by
allowing you to do homework with this by
providing you with access at home we're
partnering with Brooklyn and Queens
libraries we're partnering with Kansas
and Maine Kansas and Maine because we
want to prove that there is a solution
to the digital divide that is nationally
possible we want to prove this isn't
just about Harlem or the South Bronx or
the neighborhoods of New York this is
about everyone in America there is
something close to a hundred million
Americans who do not have what we take
for granted the access to the world of
information at your fingertip
you can't even apply for a job without
that access at this point we need to
find a way to convince the federal
government our friends at the FCC
Alberto that that we can solve the
digital divide that libraries can play a
role other institutions partners can
play a role because there is so much
more to do and it is so essential if
America leaves a third of its population
behind on the wrong side of the digital
divide we simply will not have an
economy that works and we surely will
not have a democracy that works we
couldn't be more excited to see how this
works
we're going to learn as we go it's a
great partnership and we'll be happy to
report back as we as we've learned
during this year so thanks again to my
friends from night thank you Tony up
next we have Laura Whiteman powers with
code 2040 Lauren I'm really excited to
be here I co-founded code 2040 just over
two years ago where a young organization
and we really couldn't have achieved
anything without the supporters the
people who took bets on us to kind of
allow us to make this happen so I'm
really grateful tonight for taking this
next bet on us so I'm going to talk a
little bit about kind of why after
working in the tech industry
I started code 2040 and a little bit
about what we do so code 2040 came about
because of two major trends the first is
an economic trend today science tech
engineering and math jobs are the
fastest growing category of jobs in the
US and 70% of those involve computing so
you've probably heard people say coding
is the new literacy it's really true
when it comes to where the open jobs are
in this country and at the rate that
we're
only graduating students who are
qualified to take these jobs will have 1
million jobs in tech unfilled by the
year 2020 so this is a big opportunity
the second trend is the demographics of
the US today 90% of population growth
comes from minority communities the year
2040 is the year when people of color
will collectively be the majority in the
US and at that point 42 percent of the
population will be black or Latino so
this is a new consumer base and it's
also a new workforce when we think about
who's gonna be filling jobs over the
next 5 10 25 years the issue is that
this new economy and this new demography
are actually quite disconnected so
currently boxing Latinos make up nearly
30% of the u.s. population and earn
nearly 20% of computer science degrees
but when it comes to the industry
numbers they're in less than 10% of tech
roles and when you think about who is
kind of creating these tools and
platforms as we think about a free open
Internet when you look at founders of
companies in tech less than 1% of those
backed by venture funding or black are
Latino in short we're leaving talent on
the table so we think about creating
this inclusive free open growing
innovation economy in the US and we're
missing what will be nearly half the
population when we think about who these
creators and entrepreneurs are but just
importantly just as importantly when we
think about the impact that tech can
have on these communities there's a
pretty big opportunity here as well
because these jobs that we're talking
about are not just any jobs they're
actually really great jobs so the
average salary of a tech worker is more
than the median household income of a
black family and a Latino family
combined which means that connecting
this portion of the population to these
open jobs and tech has the opportunity
to lift individuals families and
communities out of poverty and close the
Walton achievement gap in the
it states so at code 2040 we believe
this is the future of the tech industry
this is last summer's class of code 2040
fellows these 18 students black and
Latino computer science students from
around the country came together to
spend ten weeks with us last summer they
interned at tech companies and went
through code 2040s career accelerator
Fellows Program as well so when you
think about kind of the types of work
that these students are doing creating
these platforms we have students here
who worked on creating SMS banking
platforms for under banks communities
students who worked on open sourcing
parts of the code of their company's
code base so that more people could
access it really working on a lot of
really cool and exciting things during
their internship and in addition to the
internship they spend a bunch of time
with us they get mentors they work with
coaches they do company visits and get
to explore different facets of the tech
sector we do a hackathon with them where
they work on issues around diversity and
tech and think about how they can use
their skill set to not just kind of
kickstart their own career but turn
around and be mentors and role models
and create platforms and tools that
allow people from all different
backgrounds to come together get on the
web and and move the internet forward
the night support will help us this
summer
welcome 27 students to the fellows
program from around the country they are
interning at 20 different tech companies
in the Bay Area and they come from 23
different colleges and universities
everywhere from schools like MIT
Carnegie Mellon to community colleges
and state universities and colleges from
around the country so we're really
excited to welcome
them and to see what it is that they're
going to accomplish over the course of
the summer and then moving forward as we
fold them into our network and empower
them to help create new solutions and
give back so code 2040s vision is a
diverse inclusive tech sector and we
believe that we know just the people to
make it happen thank you thanks Laura
next up we have Dan Kohn right behind me
gets getting it right on rights here you
go Dan
thanks so much it's great to be here and
to be a part of this night news
challenge on the open Internet
Emily Gore our director of content and
the leader of this project for DPLA and
I are just thrilled to be part of this
attempt to strengthen the open Internet
and as Ethan said this morning you know
we are at this anniversary the 25th
anniversary of the web but I'll just
note here for you today that there were
actually forms of human expression
before the web I know I just blew your
minds right there it is true I was a
history professor for many years so you
could take my word for this and the web
is seeing an incredible flourishing of
human expression and one of the ways
really to enrich it that we envision is
by bringing online and bringing openly
available all these incredible forms of
human expression from the past to
intermingle with all the forms that are
going on today
you know these forms include maps they
include photographs they include
artworks they include manuscripts and
Diaries all this wonderful content and
that content and is held in places like
Tony Marx's New York Public Library
these incredible wonderful nonprofit
institutions that we call libraries
archives and museums and the DPLA was
founded to partner with these
institution as institutions as a digital
partner with them to help them bring
these materials online to make them
broadly accessible we launched a year
ago we've had a great first year we
brought together over 7 million items
from over 1200 institutions across the
United States and
we're still going strong increasing that
number every day but we ran into a
problem in our first year that really is
constricting our ability to share our
materials openly allow them to be reused
by people across the world and that is
that these 7 million items have 26,000
different write statements attached to
them you need a microscope here to look
at some of these write statements that
are attached to these items and that is
because there's general confusion around
these older materials about their status
if we look at them we just simply can't
use some of the things that we've seen
on the open web that have really helped
out with open expression like Creative
Commons licenses those are available on
a very small minority of the contents in
America's collections but just a very
small minority there's of course lots of
material that's still under copyright
and we work with copyright holders and
others to see how we can make that
content at least maximally open over
time but this blue area here includes
materials that are variously labeled is
unrestricted in a kind of vague way and
I'd even add a question mark there
because a lot of smaller institutions in
particular really don't know whether
their material can be put online in an
unrestricted way they're looking for
some guidance some best practices from
us and others about what they can do
with this material and there's just a
giant blue sea of material that we
simply don't know about a lot of this in
the 20 20th century that's sort of
orphaned we can't find the rights
holders we simply don't know what rights
to attach to it so we can't make it
available to everyone as freely as
possible so this project is really
simple we are going to take these
thousands of different rights statements
and streamline them into one set of
rights that will be comprehensible you
don't need a law degree to figure out if
you can reuse these amazing materials
from America's libraries archives and
museums and we're not just doing it here
in America we're doing it globally we're
trying to provide a way for that school
child who is working on a report to
create for instance a collage of openly
available materials from Boston we'd
like to see app makers come to our site
and be able to reuse this content from
thousands of Institute
Shen's into apps like open pics that
allow you to do a walking tour
wherever you are uses the GPS signals
shows historical photographs from right
around you and of course we want to
enable accounts like historical cats
which tweet out adorable pictures of
cats from throughout history from our
collection that's a form of human
expression we love you Internet it's not
Shakespeare but it is very important for
people to find ways to do these sorts of
things as I mentioned we'll be doing
this internationally we have a terrific
partner in our sister project in Europe
called Europeana
and to give you some sense of scale your
Piana has identified about 300 million
items in Europe that can be digitized
and brought online and they've just
gotten to the tip of the iceberg we have
seven million here in the u.s. that
we've brought together they're at 30
million they started a few years before
we did but only nine million items from
their collection are currently reusable
in the ways that I said so we're gonna
work with your Piana
to bring this together starting here in
2014 again we started in 2013 and if I
could end by flipping the timeline
around and hopefully inspiring you to
get involved with our projects we look
ahead really at decades of work in the
United States we very well may have a
billion items from small places cultural
heritage sites historical collections in
rural counties up to large places like
New York Public Library that we need to
bring online and to assign openly
available rights to in the best way we
can
DPLA is fanning out across the United
States as we speak to partner with more
institutions to bring those contents
online and we hope that you'll join us
in this project over not just this year
but in the coming years to bring all of
these collections together make them
available so that we can have the full
range of human expression online for
everyone thank you and thank you to the
knight foundation for their support
[Applause]
thank you Dan next we have Alan Davidson
with the global censorship measures hi
I'm uh I'm Alan Davidson with a
measurement lab or as we like to call it
em lab good morning so em lab is
designed to answer a kind of basic
question which is how can we better
understand what is happening when our
connections to the Internet don't work
the way we expect them to work so for
example a student here in Boston who's
struggling to finish their homework
trying to get access to the DPLA no
doubt because of a maddeningly slow
internet connection an activist in Egypt
who can't get Alexis to critical
election materials in the weeks before
an election a journalist in Pakistan or
Turkey or China who can't post videos at
politically sensitive moments these are
actually real-world examples that we've
encountered and they're maddening
because we don't know why they're
happening necessarily right in isolation
it's very difficult to tell what's
happening with our internet connections
but what if we could what if we could
actually collect the data from thousands
or even millions of Internet users when
their experiences what if we could
collect it and start to ask questions
like is this happening because I've been
placed in a slow lane by my ISP is this
happening because I'm suffering from
censorship from my government those are
the kinds of questions that M lab was
designed to answer so M lab is a
crowd-sourced platform for collection of
this kind of data about Internet access
it was started in 2010 and it's designed
to basically do two things one is to let
researchers create tests or experiments
on a set of servers that run around the
world and then users people can come and
run these tests on their own internet
connections and see what's happening the
goes into a public repository that then
anybody can take a look at and try to
understand what's happening not just
with an individual connection but at
aggregate what's happening within a
country within a city with within a
particular ISP there are about 150
servers running right now in about 45
different locations around the world and
the the system's already generated 900
terabytes of data like just a
sickeningly huge amount of data and
people are just beginning to learn what
we can make from all of that data we can
learn from all of that data so let me
put up a couple of obligatory kind of
geeky slides this one is just a quick
look at where m lab tests are being run
right now this was from April we're
running about almost a half a million
different tests being run each month now
and you can see they're actually
happening around the world this is this
kind of get starts to see what we can do
with some of this data so the most
popular test at M lab is of course the
network speed test right like so you can
see how fast your internet connection is
going and by looking at this data over
time we can see how different country
the the different kind of this is I
think median throughput for different
countries over time and you can or
different localities and you can see I
don't know what was going on with New
York this winter but it was bad and we
can start to ask okay now that we can
see this phenomenon how can we
investigate and try to understand what's
actually happening the idea is not just
to actually sort of be able to create
graphs like this but to actually create
some sort of knowledge that's actionable
so let me just actually skip through
this one this is a great one somebody
went through and started to use this
data to ask the question how neutral is
the net in different countries right so
this is highlights different countries
we're using M lab data we've seen
greater throttling or greater congestion
of certain kinds of services and this is
sort of a little bit of the tip of the
iceberg here's actually another
visualization I really like this one
it's actually if we had video you'd see
it's a sort of spinning globe and you
can look at based on the most recent
data coming out of M lab where the top
throttle errs are for a particular set
services and this is what we're doing
right now but it really is the tip of
the iceberg so what's the future of M
lab I should just say we are deeply
grateful for the support and honored by
the knight foundation today and the
grant that we have is actually going to
allow us to look at two of the big
challenges that we face in expanding m
lab the first is transitioning it from a
platform that's used by honestly a lot
of sort of geeky open-source developers
and researchers into a platform that can
be used by by policy makers by advocates
by journalists in an easy way this is
already beginning to happen we've seen
reports that people have used m lab data
to study censorship in Iran to
investigate the latest Comcast Netflix
kerfuffle about congestion of Netflix
traffic but the idea is to make it even
easier and this grant is actually going
to be specifically to help us with
investing the user experience and our
user interface for M lab a second thing
and a really big challenge for M lab is
how to expand the user base and this is
actually something where all of you can
help so no talk at MIT would be complete
without a homework assignment
your homework assignment your mission
should you choose to accept it tonight
is to go visit measurement lab net and
run one of our tests try the speed test
it's actually really fun try one of the
other tests in doing that you've added
your data to this large collection that
can be used by researchers to understand
what's happening with the internet tell
your friends it's something we can all
do to try to help the cause and I would
just say M lab has been a labor of love
so far by a collection of people both at
the open Technology Institute where I
work but a community of developers and
researchers who really care and they're
motivated by this knowledge that what
we've been talking about that in the
next few years we face a very serious
global debate about how much freedom
how much openness we're gonna have
online part of it is the debate we're
having in the u.s. that Alberto
referenced there's a bunch and it cites
itself in a much bigger debate globe
about these issues our hope is that em
lab can shine a light on where we're
actually seeing censorship congestion
throttling right now
and in doing so help us understand the
internet better and inform that really
important debate about freedom online so
we're deeply honored thank you very much
the knight Foundation and thank you all
go try a test tonight there's some easy
actionable impact right there that Susan
was talking about this morning so next
up we have Andrew medlar with internet
to go I'm Andrew meddler and I am
assistant chief for technology content
and innovation at Chicago Public Library
and have I got a story for you
once upon a time there was a city of
many communities it was a beautiful city
it was a dynamic engaged and connected
city but not all communities were
connected equally and in this city there
was a library it was a dynamic engaged
and connected library it was a library
that was concerned with nurturing
learning supporting economic advancement
and strengthening all communities and
especially as the largest provider of
free internet access for those citizens
it was concerned with how to do that
even more and even better and then one
day along came a knight Foundation and
this Knight Foundation said yes yes we
to care about informed and engaged
communities and we want to help you tell
and write your story and rejoicing
ensued this is a group participation
part this is where you were Joyce Joyce
again sue thank you
good we're in this together well of
course once upon a time is now
and that city is Chicago and that is a
city that led by Brenna as we saw her
thank you for the setup is involved with
the dynamic technology plan that will
accelerate citizens connectivity and
drive the economics of the city and the
quality of life for the citizens and
that library is Cpl Cpl is in every
community in the city of Chicago
it has innovative leadership and a
culture of experimentation and embracing
of the future and of course that night
is you thank you for being with us in
making this possible
now here's how together we are going to
move forward to right I think not a not
a happy ending but rather a happy
beginning for many of the citizens in
Chicago now particularly this will be
for those citizens who live in the
bright red spots on this map which is
where less than 50% of the residents
have consistent and reliable access to
the Internet
we're going to give them the opportunity
to get connected by circulating Wi-Fi
hotspots in a program called internet to
go and that will increase the citizens
comfort with digital technology and
increase the awareness that the Internet
is relevant to them because actually
that's one of the biggest villains in
this story the fact that many of those
citizens don't even know or understand
why or believe how the Internet can
actually be relevant to them now this
concept of the Internet to go is going
to build on Chicago Public Library's
precedent and tradition of circulating
information in many formats and also
many tools to support information such
as the fishing poles that we circulate
the free passes to museums and cultural
events and early literacy literacy
backpacks and most recently 500 Finch
robots donated by Google which we
circulate to
increase the ability for kids and adults
to learn computer programming programs
and skills and so just like all of these
things with the help of night and
circulating the Wi-Fi hotspots with a
single library card any Chicagoan will
have access to these in their home we'll
begin in January to increase engagement
with the internet by rolling out 300 of
these hotspots to three branches in
targeted communities communities where
we see that low Internet use and then
after just a few months of this pilot we
will double that number we'll provide
targeted digital skills and tutorials in
these communities in partnership with
the Chicago Public Library Foundation
and our cyber navigators program will
support that skill development with a
roadmap to digital proficiency and what
we'll be looking for is an increased
ability by the participants by those
checking out these devices to use these
low-cost devices to access the Internet
themselves and begin to understand and
see how it can help them with their
personal goals their career goals their
educational goals their financial goals
and why it is relevant to them well
survey participants capture staff
feedback explore irate solutions to
expansion and sustainability and we will
tell this story to others at library and
other industry and non industry events
around the world and that story is going
to be one of how we reached 10,000
people in the first year what worked and
what didn't work and how together with
our knight foundation we proved that
libraries are agile and innovative and
partners in the solution to provide
Internet access to all citizens of all
communities and that's no fairy tale
thank you
[Applause]
next up we have Jillian York Julianne
Jillian's with the online censorship org
hi I'm Jillian York and I'm gonna be
talking about a project that I
co-founded a couple years ago with a
good friend of mine runs each other so
this project is called online censorship
gorg and what we do is we crowdsource
reports
user generated reports of takedowns and
dia and account deactivations on
privately owned online platforms so
censorship but that's something only
governments do is what I hear a lot
while in fact as our conversations
increasingly take place and what we
think of is the online public sphere we
need to come to the realization that
this public sphere is in fact owned by
private companies and these private
companies are making the rules so let me
give you a couple examples of what I
mean so Facebook investigating the
removal of a post from a former vice
presidential candidate Sarah Palin what
did she say it was it something illegal
probably not Flickr taking down an
Egyptian bloggers photos after the Arab
Spring uprising and citing Community
Guidelines violations we've seen Twitter
take down repeatedly takedown accounts
belonging to foreign terrorist
organizations is this against the law
maybe maybe not but they're not
transparent about this practice and then
YouTube banning a Tunisian media site
from uploading content at all to their
platform and there are many many more
cases like this and so Rebecca MacKinnon
who's here today has talked about these
companies being the sovereigns of
cyberspace they make the rules it's
their world and we just live in this
world and this is really fundamentally
true if you look at the Terms of Service
or Community Guidelines on these
different platforms
they really do so some of them will say
for example nudity is not allowed but
there are circumstances where we think
that death threats are okay and that's
the kind of values that these companies
are bringing forward they're kind of all
over the place so what we came up with
is a platform called online censorship
org that takes reports from our users
now we're focusing in the first phase on
five popular platforms let's Google Plus
Flickr YouTube Twitter and Facebook
what we want to do is capture these
reports now users respond to a series of
questions that we're working on it
reiterating and designing to get the
best possible data that we can we'll ask
them to give us screenshots and other
evidence such as correspondence with the
companies to make our data as robust as
possible and that data will contribute
to research analysis and advocacy so the
project will be assisted by a team of
expert and academic advisors now if
anyone in this room is really interested
in the project we're looking for more
people to add to that so please come
talk to me after it'll be available in
at least eight languages so hopefully we
can make this spread as far as possible
and then add some on as we go and we'll
be enhanced by visualizations from my
co-founder Ramsay's team at visualizing
impact now what do we hope to do with
this information well the first thing is
we just want to learn about how social
media companies are enforcing their
Terms of Use and then we want to do
comparative analyses of how these
companies define certain concepts in
practice so hate speech for example most
of the online platforms that we use
every day banned hate speech and we may
or may not agree with that but how are
they defining it what does that look
like as they apply it in practice we
want to raise public awareness more
generally of corporate limitations on
speech so this is something that I find
that the more and more I talk about it
the less people seem to know about this
issue and so increasingly you know as
we're having these conversations on
Facebook or Twitter or wherever I want
people to be aware of the fact that this
is not a free speech zone so to speak
and finally we hope to engage with
companies on ways in which they can
improve their practices their terms and
their processes for dealing with this
kind of issue so that's the project if
you've got any questions for me my
contact info is there and you can follow
the project on Twitter and Facebook
thank you
Thank You Jillian and up next we have
Rebecca MacKinnon and with the ranking
digital rights Rebecca
it's very much my name is Rebecca
MacKinnon Thank You Jillian for the
shout out
I'm with ranking digital rights and we
are going to be putting out a regular
ranking of the world's most powerful
internet telecommunications and other
powerful tech companies on criteria
related to freedom of expression and
privacy what are they doing to respect
and protect their users rights and this
is very much based on an issue we've
been talking about all day the fact that
the relationship between people and
their governments and their societies
more generally is increasingly mediated
by the internet and networked mobile
devices and what we're learning and the
reason why this night news challenge
exists is because is the recognition
that this might this isn't automatically
going to turn out well we have to make
sure we actually have to actively work
to ensure that the internet evolves in a
manner that is compatible with democracy
that was compatible with decentralized
innovation and that is compatible with
human rights we have to work for that
that means that we need to make sure
that governments that are regulating and
interfering with and surveilling our
activities on the Internet are held
accountable and we also have to make
sure that companies similarly who are
shaping what you can and cannot do with
their platforms and services that they
too are held accountable and that we're
putting the right kinds of pressures and
incentives on them to make them move the
technology in the right way now there's
actually a number of efforts to
benchmark what governments are doing
this is a freedom house freedom on the
net report that they put out every day
every year and they've actually found
that Internet freedom has been declining
over the past three years and last year
it took a particularly deep dive not
good news the web index we have someone
from the world wide web foundation
renata where are you she's somewhere
around here anyway Renata is with the
web foundation they put out
web index they're also benchmarking
nation states governments on their
performance Sweden did best last year
the US and the UK particularly on
freedom and openness did really crappily
last year I wonder why and so but what
about the sovereigns of cyberspace that
Julian just referenced the the platforms
and networks that we all depend on they
are shaped by the personal ideologies of
their CEOs by the values of people who
run the companies who are shaping the
the software shaping the terms of
service the privacy policies etc there's
no benchmark how do these folks stack up
not just in the United States but
globally we talked about sort of some
global implications earlier today as
well that's what we're trying to do and
we're learning from the experience of a
number of other projects that have been
ranking companies on other issues behind
the brands published by Oxfam is
benchmarking the human rights impact of
food companies around the world you have
the access to medicines index which is
benchmarking companies on whether or not
they're actually giving access to
life-saving medicines to the people
around the world who need it most and
have the least amount of money so
there's there's evidence that companies
respond to these rankings and actually
compete to improve so we are drawing on
those lessons and that experience we're
working with sustained lytx which is a
global responsible investment research
firm that specializes in doing these
kinds of rankings and making sure that
not only are we providing information to
consumers and users who can make more
informed choices about what they want to
use but also informing investors because
we know that CEOs and boards really care
about what investors think and so this
will help to provide yet another aspect
in our theory of change to incentivize
companies to be responsible and
accountable so where are we now we've we
are getting ready to do a pilot on our
methodology you know we've been a
research and development phase and
another piece of homework for you to add
to Allan's homework that he assigned
earlier is we've put out a draft
methodology for public consultation and
we would
really love your feedback on this so
please go to our website ranking digital
rights org check out our methodology let
us know what you think are we asking the
right questions are we doing it in the
right way once we have kind of finalized
methodology we're going to be doing a
pilot on it later this year and then
hope to begin implementing the ranking
on a regular basis starting 2015 what
kinds of things are in our criteria our
companies carrying out human rights
impact assessments so before a
telecommunications company goes into oh
I don't know let's say Crimea and does a
does it does it deal with the government
there for internet access are they
carrying out a human rights impact
assessment about you know what what
their policies and practices are they
are gonna mean how transparent are
companies being about what they're doing
with your data both in terms of their
private processes but also how they're
responding to government requests many
of you have heard about transparency
reporting we're trying to incentivize
that Terms of Service what are companies
doing with their Terms of Service
jillian talked about that earlier
privacy policies you know you'd be
surprised how many companies big ones
around the world kind of barely have
privacy policies we're trying to
incentivize not only existence of them
but but good ones and and good practices
when it comes to what is in those
privacy policies and companies being
honest about what they're doing with
your data and security standards what
kinds of security standards our
company's implementing if they're
thinking about these things at all again
trying to incentivize all of these are
some types of things you can go to our
website check it out another kind of
just general request obviously we're in
the research and development phase we're
gonna be launching the ranking next year
we're looking for partners media
partners particularly to work on data
visualizations
of getting this data out who we're going
to engage with on the activism side to
make sure that public's are really
engaging with this data and making sure
that attention is called to it and that
change can happen after that so thank
you very much and I look forward to
talking to you all of you further Thanks
[Applause]
great next up we have Lilia Marcum with
tech secure Lea all right
hi everyone I'm Lilia and I'm from
Oakland whisper systems today so much
for systems makes mobile communication
apps like tech secare that protect your
privacy not that anyone here needs
something like that because I'm sure you
all have nothing to hide but let's just
say you know for the sake of argument
that some of you are journalists and you
might occasionally want to have a
private communication with the source or
maybe you're part of a group of
activists who are organizing to protest
against the government or a large
corporation you need to be able to
communicate freely and openly together
but privately or maybe you're just an
ordinary citizen and you're interested
in reclaiming your right to privacy
resisting pervasive online surveillance
and you decide you want to try this
encrypted communications thing that
people are talking about now it is
unfortunately the face of online
security is not traditionally been a
pretty one in order to even get started
with a protocol like OTR or PGP you're
gonna need some 10 page tutorial with
screenshots and explanatory text and
links to learn more maybe if you're
really lucky someone will make you a
video and post it online like this one
which was rumored to have been made by
Edward Snowden for Glenn Greenwald in
order to teach him how to use encrypted
email and it still didn't work PGP has
failed what we now know as the Greenwald
test
so at whisper systems we don't think it
has to be this hard in the security
community we know how to protect data
and in the developer community we know
how to make beautiful apps that people
want to use every day and text secures
the marriage of those two worlds it's a
secure messaging app that looks and acts
almost exactly like the messaging apps
and chat apps that you use today but it
adds a layer of security that is almost
invisible to the user
so how does it work well if you send a
message through text secured to another
text secure user whether it's text
pictures or video that content is going
to be automatically encrypted so that
only the intended recipient can read it
if you send a message to someone who's
not a text secured user it's no problem
we'll send it as a normal unencrypted
SMS like you sent every day if and when
that person decides to install text
secure all your messages from then down
forward will be automatically encrypted
another nice feature is that it saves
your SMS usage if at all possible the
encrypted content will travel over the
Internet
falling back to SMS as we need as needed
you'll see we also support emoji very
important another feature of text secure
which was just added earlier this year
is group chat so you can make a group
that has a name a picture and a list of
members all that information is part of
the encrypted content so the server
doesn't know who's in the group what
it's for and finally whether your
messages were encrypted in-flight
they're going to be encrypted at rest on
your phone which means that your
messages will not fall into the wrong
hands even if your device does okay so
that's the dream a messaging app that is
self-explanatory but also secure and
we've made a lot of progress on that we
have the axolotl protocol which is an
open encryption protocol anyone is free
to build encrypted apps on top of it
it's a collaboration between Moxie
Marlinspike and Trevor Perrin two very
well-respected minds in the field of
cryptography today using that protocol
we've developed text secure which you've
just seen it's a secure text in chat app
for Android we also have a secure
calling app for Android called read
phone and those apps are out in the wild
they are free and open source and we
have a huge community of contributors
who help us iterate and improve on them
every day but we're not done yet we
haven't quite solved the problem of
secure communication for everyone for
one thing we have no iPhone apps
released so far we are working on them
they're coming along we expect them to
be out this year we're also going to
expand to the desktop we're working on a
browser extension
so that you're not limited to just using
this protocol on your phone you can use
it from your computer and down the road
we also want to integrate our text and
voice apps into a single unified secure
communication experience that's easy
enough for everyone to use every day to
do that we're gonna need a little bit
more help although we do have a lot of
open-source contributors we have only a
couple full-time developers who are
shepherding those changes and
contributions and to like one app and
that's a full-time job so we're gonna
need more help on the development side
and on the design side and this knight
grant is really going to go directly to
that effort and make it possible for us
to bring secure communications to
everyone in their everyday lives so
thank you very much knight foundation
you want twitter handle's we've got
twitter handles and i look forward to
talking to any of you more about tech
secure later in the day and tomorrow so
thank you so much and finally we have
dan Topol agha with who are the
gatekeepers dan will jump right into the
story okay we are in Ukraine it's case
number one imagine yourself being in
Maidan square and all of a sudden you
receive a message on your mobile phone
saying the following dear subscriber you
are registered as a participant in a
mass disturbance and if you don't leave
in five minutes
you will be fined or being arrested and
this is the funny message it's not a
fake it's very true case number two we
are in Turkey now imagine yourself again
being this time a citizen of Turkey you
are waiting for the next election shadow
to take place in the following month
every morning you go to the Internet of
course searching for the news however on
this particular morning Facebook Twitter
and YouTube a couple of other websites
are all down what do these pages have in
common the fact that up until yesterday
the
have disseminated articles and text
criticizing the government and here we
are and this is not fake - this is very
real and all that
Susan is already very outraged but this
happened in reality this is not an
exercise of imagination so what do these
two cases have have in common
Ukraine and Enter key can somebody point
point point out what do they have in
common what we can observe here we can
observe the emerge of a new series of
relevant actors on the ground internet
service providers and telecom companies
we are not used to focus on these
particular companies but they started to
play together with politicians as we can
notice so I'm coming from Romania it's a
country from Eastern Europe close to
Ukraine in the middle of Ukraine and an
Turkey
fortunately all these didn't happen in
my country yet but nonetheless they can
they can happen anytime and why is that
because we don't know the name of
Internet service providers and telecom
owners I mean we know the name but we do
not know what connection they have with
politicians what connections they have
with organized crime if they have with
corruption and so forth and this
represents exactly the objective of our
project we sorry we are trying to map
the ESP and telecom owners of the region
you see the whole region in eastern
europe we have ukraine up there we have
turkey down and a whole region in
eastern europe that could have any time
this
of problems so you are asking probably
yourself why should we take care about
all this company and I will try to
summarize a little bit because so long
they remain unknown in the shadow they
can continue to manipulate and threaten
the ordinary citizens too because only
by learning about them we will be able
to put pressure on governments and
relevant authorities to change the
legislation or available regulation
where is needed and c-3 but mostly
because we should learn about these
companies because we are dealing with
new actors playing in the ground and
with a new phenomenon and if you want to
take control over the situation I think
we we must first to be able to deeply
understand it I would notice that
manipulating and controlling the access
to information we are traditional
instruments TV station radio newspaper
takes time and why not money nonetheless
politicians are always rapidly learning
the new bad habits and this will spread
in the region probably very fast because
of this capacity of learning by
politicians of course and they already
observe probably that they have the
capacity to cut off completely the
access to the information or to
distribute instant dedicated messages is
cheaper is faster is more effective to
control over these companies so I must
express in the final my gratitude for
those two who support the efforts to
improve the transparency of private and
governmental affairs
we thank the knight foundation for
supporting this project on behalf of my
colleagues from from romania and i want
to thank all of you for for your
attention thank you very much
[Applause]
great so what if we give a another round
of applause to all the winners okay
great set I think so we're doing
something a little different this year
which is we're also announcing prototype
winners for this so we have a prototype
fund that we've started at nine
Foundation which has been around for
about a year and a half and we've
changed it we've had several iterations
with it but the notion of the of the
prototype fund is that we give small
amounts of money to start or create an
early version of your idea that is
$35,000 or less shockingly they're
almost all 35,000 but we do it is in a
way of recognizing an idea that maybe
not have an organization behind it and
not fully baked yet so this is always
open they we have a deadline of August
1st for the next cohort of these so if
you have an idea that you're thinking
about and you want to test it out and
put a version of it out in the world
this is a great way to do that we also
if you're selected as a prototype winner
we do a two-day human centered design
training with the rest of the group to
help you engage with consumers and
really focus on what the problem is for
an audience that you have so we've
actually been moving prototype winners
out of the news challenge people who
submitted to the news challenge and we
moved in prototypes I mean we're doing
that kind of silently we just it was a
great intake for us around that so we
wanted though to recognize change that
up a bit and recognize that these we
think these ideas are great and that we
want to see them start iterating on it
and building out in the world so without
further ado I'm what I'm gonna do is
just tell you the idea the title of the
idea other people involved with a little
bit about it and when I call your name
just stand up in the audience and then
we'll hold our applause to the end so we
have 10 winners the first one is the
Andrew anti-censorship alert system by
Center for rites this is a series of
tools that allows the public to see a
blocked website and the project lead on
this is Tiffany Chang and
Evan Greer is here supporting the
project breeders by swell creative group
a mobile app that helps parents navigate
the technology and online content
available for their kids the lead on
that is Philip Holmes sir to dig by
University of Kansas a systems
a system that enables secure
communications and helps people verify
information online Michael Williams is
the lead there check desk by midday an
me Dan tool that helps journalists
quickly verify the source of information
in daily situations and that's Tom true
nerd right there inquisitor Lee gig a
tool that helps groups collaborate
together on complex research projects
and that Seth Kauffman and Maria
Pavarotti poking the bear yay
by selecting systems a new family of
tools that can detect improve network
neutrality violations the lead on that
is Bart Stidham report a troll by
hollaback a platform where victims can
safely report online harassment and
volunteers cannery spent respond the
project lead on that is Emily May and
Deb Johnny Roy is here with the project
safe travels online by Tibet action
Institute resources that help new users
learn how to safely navigate the
Internet that's Nathan Freitas swarm
eyes by the Guardian Media Group a tool
that allows journalists to conduct
research with the help of others Matt
McAllister is the lead on that and
finally threshold future incorporated an
internet themed virtual currency that
makes it easier for open internet
projects to find funding and the leads
on that Elizabeth Stark and Mike so fair
a round of applause for our prototype
winners
and if you already encourage you if you
want to learn more seek them out it's a
great thing again August 1st is the
deadline so if you have something that
you're thinking about doing it's open
there there's no theme this happened to
be themed because of the contest but
it's generally any idea that impacts
media information and journalism with
that we'll end our morning thanks for
paying such good attention and we have
lunch outside thank you so much
[Applause]